>> Jesse: JOE BIDEN JUST
ANNOUNCED $55 BILLION IN
REPARATIONS FOR AFRICA.
>> THE STOLEN MEN AND WOMEN AND
CHILDREN WHO ARE BROUGHT TO OUR
SHORES IN CHAINS SUBJECTED TO
UNIMAGINABLE CRUELTY.
MY NATION'S ORIGINAL SIN WAS
THAT PERIOD.
WE HONOR THEIR DESEN DENTS
GENERATIONS FOR GENERATIONS
HELPED BUILD THIS COUNTRY.
>> Jesse: ARE THE DUTCH
CHIPPING?
WHAT ABOUT THE ENGLISH IN THE
AFRICAN CHIEFS WHO SOLD SLAVES
TO THE WEST?
NOPE.
WE'RE GOING TO GET THIS CHECK.
SO, ARE THEY GOING TO GET
REPARATIONS IN CASH?
GOLD?
BITCOIN?
NO.
SOLAR PANELS.
>> TODAY'S ANNOUNCEMENT JOIN A
PORTFOLIO OF PARTNERSHIP FOR
GLOBAL INFRASTRUCTURE AND
INVESTMENT PROJECTS ALREADY
UNDERWAY IN AFRICA, INCLUDING
MOBILIZING $8 BILLION IN PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE FINANCE TO HELP
SOUTH AFRICA REPLACE COAL FIRED
POWER PLANTS WITH RENEWABLE
ENERGY SOURCES AND CUTTING EDGE
ENERGY SOURCES LIKE CLEAN
HYDROGEN.
>> Jesse: SORRY ABOUT SLAVERY
HERE IS A SOLAR PANEL.
>> IF YOU WORK IN A COAL MINE
YOU ARE FIRED.
IS THIS WHAT AFRICA NEEDS RIGHT
NOW?
YOU CAN'T RUN A CONTINENT ON
GREEN.
YOU CAN'T JUST SKIP
INDUSTRIALIZATION AND GO
STRAIGHT TO WIND MILLS.
AFRICA IS NEVER GOING TO GET OUT
OF POVERTY BY KILLING COAL.
LET'S GET THE AFRICAN ECONOMY
SPINNING FIRST BEFORE WE START
INSTALLING CHECK TRICK CAR
CHARGING STATIONS ALONG THE
NILE.
RENEWABLES ARE JUST A SIDE DISH.
FOSSIL FUELS THE MAIN COURSE.
AND I'M OPEN TO LISTENING TO
PEOPLE WHO FEEL BLACK PEOPLE ARE
OWED SOMETHING FROM A COUNTRY
THAT ENSLAVES THEIR ANCESTORS
BUT THESE GREEN REPARATIONS ARE
GOING TO KEEP AFRICA IN POVERTY.
AND WHAT ABOUT SLAVERY
REPARATIONS IN AMERICA?
BECAUSE THOSE ARE COMING.
NEWSOM IN CALIFORNIA WANTS TO
HAND OUT HALF A TRILLION DOLLARS
IN REPARATIONS.
A QUARTER MILLION TO ANY BLACK
PERSON WHOSE ANCESTORS FACED
HOUSING DISCRIMINATION.
THAT IS A FORTUNE.
BUT A LOT OF CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS SAY THAT'S NOT ENOUGH.
SO NEWSOM'S REPARATIONS TASK
FORCE ASKED FOR ADVICE FROM THE
COMMUNITY.
WHAT MORE CAN WE DO FOR YOU?
AND HERE'S WHAT THEY HEARD.
>> AT THE END OF THE DAY, ANY
AMOUNT IS TOO LITTLE AND EVERY
AMOUNT IS NEVER ENOUGH.
>>
>> YOUR JOB IS TO HEAR US.
>> WE TRANSPARENCY.
FIRST THING I SAID YESTERDAY THE
DEAD PEOPLE.
DEAD HOMES.
THERE WILL BE RESPECTED TO GET
REPARATIONS AS WELL TO PASS OUT
TO THEIR PEOPLE.
>> I THINK THE REPARATIONS
SHOULD BE AS FOLLOWS:  IT'S TO
BE GIFTED TO US WITH A GOLD AND
SILVER BOWLIAN MAYAN AT THE
BELLA SLAVES AND ANCESTORS AND
HEIRS 1 OUNCE OF GOLD AND SILVER
FOR EACH ANTEBELLUM SLAVE AND
DESCENDENTS ACCORDING TO THE
CONDITIONS OF THE MOTHER FOR SIX
GENERATIONS THAT EQUALS 724
METRIC TONS OF GOLD AND SILVER
BOWL I DON'T KNOW.
SO WE ARE ASKING THAT YOU GIVE
US REPARATIONS BECAUSE AMERICA
IS NUMBER ONE ON GOD'S LIST TO
BE DESTROYED.
SO IF YOU DON'T ACCOMMODATE US
AND YOU DON'T ASSIST US JUST
WATCH WHAT OUR GOD IS GOING TO
DO TO AMERICA.
>> AMERICA IS BENEFITING FROM
SLAVERY AND FROM WHAT OUR
ANCESTORS DID THAT WE NEVER GOT
PAID FOR.
AND I HOPE THAT YOU GUYS SUE
EVERY OTHER COUNTRY THAT HAS
BENEFITED FROM SLAVERY.
>> $200,000 IS NOTHING FOR WHAT
MY FAMILY HAS CONTRIBUTED TO
THIS COUNTRY.
REPARATIONS DEAD BROTHERS AND
SISTERS.
REPARATION UNLESS GOLD BARS.
IF YOU DON'T PAY UP GOD IS GOING
TO STRIKE YOU DOWN.
IT'S GOING TO BE A FUN DEBATE.
THIS REPARATIONS PACKAGE IS
GOING TO MAKE COVID RELIEF LOOK
TEENSY.
DO YOU THINK THERE IS GOING TO
BE A LITTLE FRAUD?
THIS IS THE SAME STATE THAT
BROUGHT YOU THE $2 MILLION
PUBLIC TOILET.
THE 400 MILLION SUICIDE NET AND
WHO GIVES YOU $1,200 A MONTH FOR
BEING TRANS, WHICH THEY PAY ON
THE HONOR SYSTEM.
BUT IT'S NOT JUST CALIFORNIA.
PLANS FOR REPARATIONS ARE
SPOUTING UP ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
BOSTON, ILLINOIS, ST. LOUIS,
DOZENS OF CITIES AND STATES.
IN PROVIDENCE, THEY CARVED OUT
10 MILLION IN THEIR BUDGET FOR
REPARATIONS BUT THEIR
QUALIFICATIONS ARE SO LOOSE THAT
EVEN WHITE PEOPLE ARE ELIGIBLE.
AS LONG AS THEY MAKE UNDER 50
GRAND A YEAR.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS WHEN YOU ARE
GIVING OUT FREE MONEY, THERE'S
NEVER ENOUGH.
AND ANYBODY WHO DOESN'T GET CASH
IS GOING TO SAY WELL, WHAT ABOUT
ME?
DID THE JAPANESE GET ANYTHING?
FDR PUT THEM IN INTERNMENT
CAMPS?
WHAT ABOUT NATIVE AMERICANS?
THE TRAIL OF TEARS HAS TO COST
SOMETHING.
WOMEN WERE DISENFRANCHISED FOR
DECADES.
SHOULDN'T THEY GET BACK PAY?
MEXICAN AMERICANS DESERVE
REPARATIONS.
WE CONQUERED TEXAS AND THAT WAS
MEAN.
IF YOU HAD TO BET, DO YOU THINK
SLAVERY REPARATIONS IS GOING TO
BE GOOD OR BAD FOR RACE
RELATIONS?
AND IS ANCESTRY.COM NOW LIKE THE
NEW OBAMACARE WEBSITE?
AND IF YOU THOUGHT LAWYERS WERE
DESTROYING AMERICA, WHICH I DO,
WAIT UNTIL THE LAWYERS GET
INVOLVED.
DO WE GIVE THE GOVERNMENT OUR
D.N.A. NOW OR PULL OUT THE OLD
FAMILY TREE FROM THE ATTIC?
DUST IT OFF?
"PRIMETIME" IS WARNI